I'm very excited to welcome back.
Ooh,
one of those incredible women on Kumar.
So many of you may remember Anjalee
as one of our fearless lawyers,
a senior counsel who worked on
projects from Google x to youtube,
but many more of you may remember Anjalee
for hosting the Act Google Speaker
series, bringing in incredible
chefs like Anthony Bordain.
Um, Jacques Pepin, Marcus Samuelsson.
I hope you got some really good
secret recipes from Ali's [inaudible].
Got a lot of really great reservations.
I will tell you, I still know cod. Yeah.
Was Nice.
Um,
and to entertainers like quest love
who you might remember from her series
lunchtime at Google shortly,
but it's so fun. Delightful.
Um,
Anjalee like most of us knows that most
people's hearts live in their stomach
and so you're always having people
who could talk to us about food.
So after leaving Google Anjalee went to
be founding general counsel and founding
head of social innovation at Warby Parker.
And most recently was the chief
people officer at Cheddar.
And throughout these jobs,
Anjali was also pretty busy starting a
family with her beloved husband at tool
in 2010.
She had a daughter Zia and it was right
around then and that she started to
think about religion.
And as a new mom myself,
I can totally relate to the fact that
there's nothing like having a baby to make
you peek your head up around
out of your bubble and say,
how do I explain the
mysteries of life? Yeah. Um,
so Angela is here today to tell us a
little bit about how she turned over every
rock in what seemed like every corner
of the worlds religions and spiritual
groups and sects in her incredibly
delightful book stocking God.
So without further ado,
please help me give a warm
welcome back to Angela Kumar.
How'd you so much for having me?
It's such a thrill to be
here and to actually not know
everybody in the audience
means that more Googler showed up and
just my team, which still meeting.
So Anjalee tell us a
little bit about yourself.
Like what was life like growing
up for you? Where did you grow up?
How did you kind of get to this place
where you were asking all these questions?
It's
sure.
So I was born in Brooklyn actually,
but raised outside of Chicago,
Real Brooklyn Woo Woo for Brooklyn and
raised outside of Chicago by Indian
parents. I'm John is my religion.
So it's sort of a small,
very minority of religion,
at least outside of India,
but raised culturally Hindu and
also went to Catholic school.
Like you might get a sense of why I
wrote this book when you start hearing
because I'm not like there are a lot of
religion and a lot of traditions around
me.
And it,
for me it was really cultural and it was
just something that I never really much
about or questioned because it was so
seamlessly interwoven into our lives.
And I just never felt the need to ask
the big questions. And as you said,
it was when my daughter is zeal was more
in, which happened when I was at Google,
not physically at Google, but where do,
oh, hold on. We're having a mic and show.
Oh, keep going. Okay. So, um,
it was while I was employed at Google,
I had my daughter Zia about eight
years ago, almost nine years ago.
And it was in a conversation with my dad
when he said to me soon after she was
born, he was like, Oh, you
should take her to the temple.
There's a John Temple out in queens and
you should take her there to show her
what we believe. And I was like,
what do we believe? I was like, Huh,
that's a really interesting question. I
was like, what do we believe? It was like,
wait,
did I miss something?
Because I was injured the traditions and
I wanted to do all the right things and
like, you know, check off all the
traditional boxes. But I was like,
I don't really know what I believe.
And I just had never thought about it.
So I decided to start researching because
I realized there was at some point
there be the set of questions that my
daughter would inevitably ask me. Like,
what happens when you die? Is there
a god? How'd you find happiness?
What's the meaning of life? Things
that I could not Google an answer too,
but early, that was the
start of the journey. Um,
and so I started doing research and I
was like, well, what do I really believe?
And maybe I'll go see this healer
and go do this other thing.
And it started as a very quiet thing
because I worked at Google and I was like,
everyone's going to think I'm in bananas.
And I worked at Google in the legal
department, so the last thing you want is,
are like going off and doing
all this crazy stuff. Um,
but then as I started telling people, and
so, especially colleagues, a Google ad,
they, they really surprised me
because they started being like, oh,
have you checked out this thing? I'm
like, I know this healer downtown,
or I saw this showman, or I've tried
Iowasca or whatever. And I was like, what?
I was like, everybody's doing
this stuff except for me.
So like I'm the only one
who hasn't been searching.
And that's what's sort of the whole,
I, well, I was looking, um,
while I was thinking about like,
what can I talk with you about?
I was looking at emails that we
exchanged and there was one titled Amaa.
Um, and you and I are both
friends with Gopi, um,
who are extraordinary. As I said,
if you guys don't know Gopi should,
but he started the Yoga [inaudible] group
and he teaches yoga out in California
amongst the many other things that he
does, including being a Googler. And um,
he turned a lot of us on to Emma who's,
who's sort of the hugging saint. Um,
and I know you wrote about Alma in your,
in your book.
Can you tell us a little bit about her?
She's actually my opening chapter.
Um,
and it was through a conversation
with Gopi where he was like, oh,
I follow this woman, I'm a, she goes
around the world literally hugging people.
That's her job. That's what she does. It
sounds like, I mean, kind of a weird job,
but it's, you know, she
makes a lot of money doing this and so
she goes around the world giving hugs and
she was coming just to midtown
Manhattan and it was July 4th weekend,
many summers ago. So I was like,
well, I'm going to go check it out.
And I jumped in a cab and I go there
and it was, it was so interesting.
It was like lines out the door,
thousands, thousands of people.
I stood in line for probably over four
hours waiting for a hug and then have
this experience of like settling in and
like, it was like an overfamiliar Auntie.
And you know, if you've ever experienced
that, what you're kind of like,
this is getting uncomfortable. Like I'm
just, can you let you, she won't let go.
But then suddenly you're like peeled
off of her and like thrown off too.
You don't like just like a puppy but
like just thrown off. And it was um,
deeply unsatisfying for me personally,
but so satisfying to so many
people there who were in tears,
having hugs from her and who
are really deep followers.
And I think that also helped me sort of
go into all of these experiences with a
really open mind being like, you know,
just because it's not right for me.
There might be something that I can
take from it and then continue on the
journey to find what
really resonates for me.
But then I really respect the fact that
Gobi and other friends of mine really
believe in her and really
follow her around the world
and go every summer to get
a hug from her. I have not gone back,
but there's great food when you go.
And so if you're not into the hug,
there's amazing vegetarian food in the
basement of the hall. It's nice. Yeah.
There's always something
redeeming and all of these things.
So speaking of belief, your husband
is a doctor, right? As a scientist,
what did he, what did he think
about things as the Nanas?
What do you think he is?
Um, he is the most patient
man in the universe.
So he is an interventional cardiologists.
Like he's a super amount of science.
And He, I think for him,
again, so much of spirituality,
religion has just been cultural for him.
So he doesn't really think about it.
He doesn't waver around these questions.
He sort of goes through
the motions of religion.
He's Hindu was raised Hindu and I think
if pressed would call himself into,
um,
but he definitely,
there were moments when I was doing
the research where he's like, yeah,
you're not going to do that.
I'm like, that's crazy.
Or when I would come back from
things and he was like, oh, my word.
Like to like the, um, the chanting, the
tantric sound healing. I think that was,
that definitely tested our relationship,
but he's got a good sense of humor.
So he mostly went along with it. Nice.
Yeah, he did not come with me on it.
Anything that stuff? No, just one. He did
the meditation with me. He learned TM.
He didn't do the Vipassana,
but he did a transcendental
meditation course with me.
But I found out later from him it was
because I had told him about all of these
athletes that did it with professional
athletes that he really respected and
admired. So he was like, oh, really?
Like that's kind of cool. It was like,
you're not a football player. Like, when
do you think this is gonna come in handy?
But he was really into like the
mental toughness aspect of it.
I really want to do it
because of David Lynch. So I,
that's where I learned David Lynch.
Let me write some sort of crazy.
It's going to let you write a
book and telling you. Yeah, baby.
I caught the big fish,
which is a book by David Lynch. Um, so
after you went to Alabama, what was sort
of like your next staff? Like you're,
you're, you're like, okay, I
did this. I'm in New York City.
This doesn't work for me. I know you
started traveling around the world.
You mentioned that your
husband didn't go with you,
but I know your sister went with you
to Brazil, right. To See John of God.
And so I thought the John of God's
story was particularly a little crazy.
So John of God,
um,
my sister and does not appear in the
chapter because the narrative just worked
better without her in it. But she was
there with me. John of God is a healer.
That a medium is what they consider him.
So there's a lot of
people around the world,
including Oprah who really believe
that he can cure all that ails you,
whether physical, emotional, spiritual.
And so people will go down to see him in
the small town in the middle of Brazil
and do get healing.
He sorta just pass in front of him and
you meditate for days and that kind of
thing. And, and he scans I guess
your oric field and then heels you,
I don't fully know how it works
because it's definitely out there. Um,
but people really believe in him and
really he does surgery on people. Yeah,
that's crazy. That stuff is, yeah, he
does surgery without anesthesia. Um,
sometimes there's cutting and he claims
that he cuts because the people need to
see the cut.
Like the patient needs to see the cut,
but not because it's actually required.
But there are people who say that they
had been cured of cancer and a lot of
other things by going to see each other.
Did you see any surgeries while
you were there? You saw some,
some cutting and some eyeball scraping.
It was really, it was really out there.
Um,
and it became,
it ended up becoming a real anchor for
me in the narrative of this particular
book.
So it's one of the first chapters of
the book of going down to seeing him and
you know, what happens there. And
then when the conclusion comes,
it sort of ties the whole thing up of
what I found on this very long journey.
Um,
because of things that happened related
to him but not directly from him.
So tell me more about that. Sure. And
so when you go to see John of God,
you can also make wishes and so you go
down with your three intentions and sort
of like wishing for, you know,
through a genie in a bottle.
And what you can also do is
bring photographs of other
people who would like to
be seen. My John of God,
who can't make the trip.
So you can save them the airfare down in
Brazil and he will scan the photographs
and apparently do distance healing.
So I guess if you believe that he
can heal you by looking at you,
it's probably not that much of a leap
to think that he could also heal other
people by scanning of voter photograph.
So when I was going down,
I started offering to people, including
some colleagues at Google, um,
that I could take their pictures down
and that I could also take their wishes
down if they wanted.
And then I started telling around
people because I'm super chatty.
And so I was telling like the guy at the
coffee shop and like the lady at whole
foods and all these other people who have
like a stack of photos with you. Yeah.
So I ended up getting
bombarded with emails,
like to the point where
it was really crazy.
Like I just so many emails and I had to
go run and get a bunch of photos printed,
uh, you know, the local
Dwayne Reed and whatever.
And so I went down with all these
wishes and all these photographs. Um,
and it wasn't until I was
kind of researching the
entire book and working on the
conclusion that I went back and actually
read the emails with a fresh eye and I
noticed a few things in common amongst
the emails and there were, you know,
there are some things that were
not necessarily as interesting.
Like people gave me very specific
instructions on how they could be reached.
It was like, just in case this
shit's real. Oop, sorry. Ah,
it in cases Israel, uh, I want to make
sure my wishes going to the right person.
Right. So they gave me like a
full addresses apartment numbers,
like where they could be reached then the
end of class. Yeah. It was like, don't,
don't let them screw it up.
If this is going to be real.
I want to make sure the wishes are coming.
Like the,
the good stuff is coming
to my house. Yeah. Um,
the second thing that I
saw in these wishes is that
everybody was asking for the
same things and it was health,
happiness and love.
And it was in that order. And then the
third thing is that they all ended,
every single email I ended in
the same way. And they all said,
please don't tell anyone. Which I
thought was like, I'm telling all of you.
I see me. Um, I also told a bunch of
people at Ted and laying everywhere.
I did it on the stage and I wrote it
in my book. So I've told everybody,
but I think it's because
it's really important.
It's important for us to know
that we at the end of the day,
mostly all want the same thing,
right? So at the end of the day,
despite all of our differences and all
the things that we might be searching for
that are different, um, all the political
divides, the religious divides us,
you know,
every other philosophical divide in the
divisive time that at the end of the
day, we really all want the
same things. It reminds me of,
um, one of the things you talk about
in your book, which is burning man.
So I've been to burning man and,
and you go,
you have the opportunity to write on
the wall of the temple. The temple,
something usually like a letter to someone
who's passed or wishes or whatever.
Um, and I found that to
be really moving. Um,
can you tell us a little bit
about your experience there?
I know there's somebody in the
audience here. You went to burning man.
I met him at burning man.
We didn't even know each other.
Google and we were in the same camp.
Um,
I feel like everybody at Google
was wanting to burning man,
isn't it a job requirement?
There's nodding heads.
So if you can imagine me as a
lawyer going into burning man,
I mean like a reasonably uptight
person going to burning man.
You can just do the math on what
that experience was like. For me,
it was really uncomfortable at
first and I went and I was like,
I feel so out of place and I don't know
what I am doing here and I don't have
clothes to radically self express myself.
Like I had to borrow this outfit from
somebody. Like I don't Ha, you know, I am.
I worked in tech. No, I
did not have costumes.
I don't have a lot of feathers
in my wardrobe. You don't like,
I don't have stuff to
where it burning man.
No one's going to see me in a bikini top.
Like it's just not happening.
I've had a child,
it's not happening.
So going there was really
out of my comfort zone to
put myself in that situation
and I ended up loving it
after a couple of days.
Like once I kinda got in my groove and
got over myself and got over the and not
over the the general lack of dryness.
Yeah,
just the dryness and the lack of
sanitary conditions around bathrooms.
I once I got over that I was,
I really enjoyed it and I felt like,
um, I, you know, I feel like you really,
that cliche of what you need out of
that experience is truly what you get.
And I think that was true for me.
I got a lot of rest at burning man.
I think I was the only person who
came back reasonably well. Preston,
which also just tells you what
a nerd I am. Cause I was like,
[inaudible] I'm going to go to sleep.
Like I just was like,
not the person staying up until five in
the morning and like doing drugs in the
desert. Like I was just like, no, I'm
just going to go read a book and like,
you know, sleep in the healing dome.
Like I was really taking it easy. Um,
but I engage with it in a way that was
comfortable for me and I think I got out
of it what I needed to.
And the temple I think was a particularly
powerful thing for me as well.
Did you write something? Yeah, I left a
lot of wishes for friends. Again, sort of,
I think part of the journey and the way
I've kind of justified indulging in this
journey, it was taking people along
with me virtually or mentally,
wherever I could. So going to burning
man, it's like who else has got a wish?
Like I'll put it in a temple
for you. And so, you know,
writing those for people was a really
emotionally cathartic experience in a way
that I was really surprised by.
Like people who are mourning friends
and loved ones, including a Googler,
you know,
who had died in the Nepal earthquake,
who you all probably remember who is a
friend of mine and a friend of a lot of
friends in common.
Um,
and so just being able to bear
witness to that and to, you know,
to kind of mark that for his mom and
for his friends was really meaningful.
And so I think again,
I got,
I got out of it what I needed to and
it's my favorite chapter in the box.
So there's also that, which
is, so speaking of the book,
when I was reading it,
um,
every night I would sort of come
home and be like, yet, wonder what,
what wacky store here tonight?
And it's sort of like hanging
out with you on like, you know,
and getting to hear all
of your best stories.
So what do you think of all
of these wacky adventures?
Like what's the craziest thing
that you saw? I would say,
uh,
the tantric sound healing was probably
one of the more out there experiences.
My, my dad read the book and he, when the
galleys came out and he was just like,
he couldn't look me in the eye for a
couple of days. Like he was just like,
what on earth are you up to? And can you
go back to Google? Are they still hiring?
Can you go back and do you
feel comfortable telling
these guys? Sure. Yeah.
So it's um,
the,
the experience was I actually went after
a Google sales conference because we
had sales conference out in health
go with Google salespeople. No,
nobody from Google joined me.
I should have asked people.
I did not invite anyone
on that particular truck,
but other friends of mine
who is a screenwriter was
going to this thing down in
southern California right outside
of La and Santa Barbara and it,
and she told me about it.
And so I went to meet her after Google
sales conference cause I was already on
the west coast. So a lot of the things,
it sounds like a very diligent like, oh,
I'm like privilege and flying all over
the world that I really did tack a lot of
the things that I did on to work.
Travel, not just Google were child,
but just like generally because I'm a
mom and I have a budget and I'm a working
person. And so trying to coordinate
these things into real life is,
was part of the challenge.
And part of the reason the book
talks along the research. Um,
but how long they would take.
I worked on it.
I probably researched,
I started at when Xeo was about one,
she's turning nine in February. The bulky,
I mean, probably like six, seven years.
I mean, every research and writing, I'm
not constantly obviously, but like, yeah,
over the course of six years, it's
a full time thing. Yeah. Yeah.
Um,
and so he basically,
you lie on the ground and this,
this guy is like a 65,
seven year old Indian man
who was not my husband.
He lies on top of you. There's a
sheet between you. So it's not,
it's weirdly not sexual. I
mean, not for me at least. So.
So he lies on top of
you and then he chance,
I can't believe I'm telling
the story of Google,
he founded itchy your shock rub points.
So if you know your shockers are,
you can use your imagination of
what that entails. But he had like,
he sounds into your,
into your head and then like her throat,
then you all the way down,
all the way down. It goes
all the way down. And it was,
it was super bizarre. I
mean, as you can imagine,
so he's doing this and it goes on
for like 45 minutes to really, yeah,
like you're committed to this experience
and then it's a group activity because
there's people who are
not all doing it with him,
but they're all sitting around you
as this is happening. So again,
I mean it's just, it was, that's, that
just wrote itself. I don't, you know,
I don't know how you write about that
and share that experience with people if
you have experienced it herself.
But it was, it was crazy,
but it was also on legal moxie.
Like it was really,
it was like having noise
canceling headphones on or
being surrounded by like bs,
but they're not stinging you like just the
humming. Huh? I know it sounds strange.
It was actually kind of delightful.
I haven't gone back but I probably
should cause it was there.
There are people who really enjoyed it.
I'm much more than I did but that aint
give me his number. He's on Facebook.
He follows me on Facebook. Oh awesome. So,
so, so, so speaking of
group group activities,
one of the things you talk about is
going to this Wiccan, potluck dinner.
Can you tell us a little bit about that?
Because I found those,
so when I think about Wicca, I'm kind
of like, these are witches and you know,
I don't really know what that means.
And it sounds a little dark.
But that chapter was super
lighthearted and, and women seemed really
lovely. Yeah, everybody was amazing.
That was actually one of the chapters
that I think really challenged my own,
I guess unconscious bias against witches.
I didn't know I had it,
but it was the one thing I
know, I'm sorry. It's anyone
in here as a Wiccan, like,
I'm, I'm fully converted. Like I'm, I'm
in it. I really respect what you do.
Um, the, that was the one thing that
my editor actually encouraged me to do.
So everything else was
basically researched and
planned of what I was doing.
Right. Already done the research. And
my editor was like, you know, the one,
the gap that you have in this is Wicca.
And I was like, why? Like I, you know,
I had this really childlike,
um,
preconception of what it would mean to
be Wikipedia, black pointy hats. Like I,
you know, my kid watches Disney movies.
Like I would, that's what I was picturing,
which is so, you know, it's,
it's such an unconscious bias.
Like I didn't even realize that I have
this bias against witches. And I was like,
oh, I don't want to do that. It's kind
of scary. Like I don't want to do that.
And then she kind of kept encouraging me.
She's like,
I feel like that's the one thing that
people do when they first step out of
traditional religion that a lot of people
explore that. And I was like, all right,
fine. So I started researching it and as
I researched more and more, I was like,
this is actually super
interesting because it is, um,
there was no like rulebook right?
Like it really is a choose what you want.
I'll let and practice the AH,
um,
in a way that I think so much of us who
don't ascribe to a specific religion or
religious tradition but still want to
find something and some meaning would
actually be like, oh
yeah, that makes sense.
Like I believe in equal like eating
seasonally or would have, you know,
like I respect nature. Like I do a lot of
the things that are core principles. Um,
I believe in being good to people and
hoping that that comes back to me and that
kind of thing. And so
going, I went to a potluck,
it was a Thanksgiving potluck for,
but not related to our,
like to American thanksgiving.
It was, I guess Wicca,
thanksgiving because there was a
little bit, when is wicked thanks.
It was right around my daughter's
homecoming times. So like it was probably,
I think October, September, October. I
think it's done by the lunar Oh yeah.
Must be harvest. Yeah. It's
like Harvard. Exactly. Um,
and it was at the LGBT center
in Manhattan and it was,
it was really wonderful.
Like after you got off,
after I got over the sort of initial
awkwardness of just dining with strangers.
It was, they, it was such a wonderful,
warm group of people. I know.
It's really just people again
searching like the rest of us, right?
They just trying to find community,
trying to find connection. Um,
a lot of people were new to the city
and they were just looking for somebody
else to have that kind of moment with.
And it was a really lovely
dinner and these witches
could cook. It was good food.
My contributions were lackluster,
but there's where we're quite delicious.
It was a really,
it was a really special evening.
So was there any time during this,
I guess, journey where you are,
like your curiosity was really peaked
about a particular religion where you were
saying, maybe I'll actually go
in that direction. You know,
I didn't really do
traditional religious stuff.
So I mean if Waco was probably the most
traditional religion that I explored
there's, and it gives you an
idea. Yeah. So there weren't,
the meditation was really powerful for me.
I think that's something that I had
started doing when I worked at Google.
In fact to end the TM, the TM hard. Um,
and that's a practice that's really stuck
with me and that's become almost like
mental hygiene for me. Like
our daily flossing, right?
Like I just do it because it feels good
and it's not like your teeth will fall
out if you don't floss one day, but you
kind of feel achy all day. It's like,
that's what I feel like about meditation.
It's like if I download a 10 minutes in
the morning and 10 minutes and I do 20
minutes in the morning,
I used to be able to do 20 minutes in
the afternoon when I worked here because
they have things like because a
girl and it cause Google. I know,
but then don't leave Google ever.
You can never do that kind of
stuff when you leave this place.
There is no meditation room at other
startups, like they don't have the space.
And so that practice fall by the wayside
when I left Google, but when I was here,
it was something that I did, you
know, twice a day and was pretty,
pretty committed to it. Um, so that's
a practice that's really stuck for me.
And in terms of the other things,
not really,
like none of them are things
that I've been like, oh,
I want to go back to that again and
again and I think this is my thing. So,
but I think I've gotten it to be okay with
that. I sort of got to the end of the,
the journey, at least for the
narrative of this story, um,
and got comfortable with just sort of
stopping for a minute. When was that?
What has,
you know,
I did bring a plus into the wine on the
silent meditation retreat and I think
just being still for that long
and shutting up for awhile,
it was really good for me and it got me
out of my head and it got me out of this
sort of frantic search and just
being like, you know, you kind of,
you probably know the answers
to a lot of the things,
at least what's true for you if you just
quiet down a little bit and stopped for
a minute.
And so that's what I ultimately did.
I sort of stopped the frantic search.
It felt like a nice natural ending to
the story for this particular book.
And I don't have that same kind of,
um,
urgency around answering these questions,
but I still, you know, people ask me to
do stuff all the time and I'm like, yeah,
let's go do that.
Like it's,
I think the curiosity and the
search of it is still fun for me.
So I every so often we'll
go do it. Like, yeah,
I'm pretty sure if you asked any of the
people in this audience they want to
come with you, including
me. So I have to ask,
what about Zia?
Like what was the end result for her?
She must've seen you doing this.
She knew you published the book.
Like how did this impact her life?
Yeah,
so she was really little when I
was doing most of the research.
And so I think she just thinks I'm sort
of cookie and like always off doing
things.
It was concerning when she would tell
her her teachers about where you can
imagine like a button hadn't
private school. Like they were like,
oh we heard you weren't talking for a few
days. I'm like what is everything okay.
And I was like, no, I was
at a retreat. You know,
like they're like or kindergarten teachers
were super concerned when I came back
from that, from that silent retreat. Um,
cause he would just give them a bit
of information. But I think, you know,
what's been the most interesting
thing for the questions,
she does ask me questions that are
themed to the book and we just have
conversations about it. I'm like,
what do you think the answer is? Like,
I don't know what happens when you die.
Like what do you think?
And she actually weirdly has a very easy
relationship with the idea of death.
Like that's something that since
she was little, I had told her, um,
actually went down Frydenberg who died.
I had told her that when people die,
um,
but they become stars in the sky.
My husband and I had told her that's
because she had come across a picture of
his mother who had,
has to wait when he was quite young.
And I don't know why we said that,
but that's what we kind of turned to
were like, yeah, they become star.
She was like three.
And so when don passed away and she
heard me on the phone talking to somebody
and getting the news, she's
like, what happened? And I
said, well, you know, a good,
a good friend of, of our friends, um,
died in an earthquake and she's like,
she's her pauses. And she's like, Oh,
you mean you became a star in
the sky? And I was like, Oh yeah,
I think he did. You know,
it was just a really, like,
maybe I'm not screwing this up so badly,
but it was really beautiful moment.
It sounds,
and you also described to me another
beautiful moment about the library and in
your daughters saw, I wondered if
you would tell all of these. Yeah,
so not really related to
the spirituality piece,
but I think just the idea of all these
conversations we're having and in a place
like Google or just across corporate
America or Hollywood or anywhere around
diversity and inclusiveness. And one of
the things that I did not expect was, um,
how much that having that book
on a shelf would mean to me.
And so the story we were talking about,
um,
when my book came out soon after my
daughter's school librarian, you know,
to send me a text and she was like,
oh,
she sent me a picture of the book and
the School Library and she's like, oh,
we just got a copy of your book
and the next time your end,
could you sign it for us? And I just
started crying and I was so surprised.
Like this is the most impactful thing.
Like I've done a Ted talk and I was like,
this is the moment where I was like,
I can't believe that my little kid will
walk into a school library to her school
library and see a story
that literally reflects her,
reflects her story in some way back
to her [inaudible] I get like a little
choked up thinking about it and it's,
it had meant so much to me because
growing up in this country,
in the time that I grew up,
uh,
I did not have that expectation and I
didn't even know it was an option. Like,
I didn't know to be,
I didn't know I was being cut out of a
narrative or that my narrative didn't
exist on the library shelves
or in Hollywood or anything
else. They're just like,
oh, I'm an recent immigrant
to this country. Like,
why would my story of nobody would
tell your style, like, you know,
why'd to watch Bollywood films?
And that's definitely not my narrative,
but that's,
you know,
that's what I would watch to see
somebody who looked like me, um,
and definitely can downs
like me, uh, on the screen.
But it wasn't something
I had an expectation of.
And to know that she and her friends
would have that experience was so,
so moving and meaningful to
me in a way that it wasn't
expected. Yeah. So,
so what now, so what are, what
are you doing now? Oh Gosh,
a million dollar question.
I'm trying to come back to Google.
I've decided that I can just
hide out in the hallways.
None of you would even notice. Like
I could just stay here forever. Now.
I am kidding. I am. Uh, the
book came out a bit ago,
a few months ago,
and so there's been some great,
exciting and trust around turning
it into television and some way,
which it would be been.
Talk about like seeing yourself on screen.
Not that I would be in it, but that
other people would, would play you. Ooh.
Who are you thinking play you?
Julia Roberts? No, I don't know.
I'm totally getting, um, I don't know.
I like the idea of Archie Panjabi
do you guys remember from like,
not like back home? She played her
sister and, but I was like, fuck,
I'm just super funny and like really like,
she was like quick and funny.
I really liked her.
Um, so yeah, maybe her,
and then I told my husband
that Dev Patel should play him
just saying, and he started getting
annoyed with me because I'm like,
did you see him in Gq? Like he's
somewhat sometimes minor. Like this guy,
he got super cute. You should, he should
play you. And he's like, you got to stop.
So I'm going to, I was, yeah, it was,
it was only funny to me apparently.
But I hit on him in a gym once
you did it. Yeah, it's great.
We'll talk about that in the after show.
That's um,
so that, yeah. So there's
some talk of that, which would
be really, really exciting.
Um, I'm thinking about if I would
write another book. I don't know.
I'm doing some writing different,
like sort of my first time
doing different things.
I was just a clown in the Macy's
Day parade. Yeah, Super Fun.
There's definitely an article there.
I highly recommend all of you to do that.
If you ever have the opportunity,
you can volunteer to be a clown in
the Macy's Thanksgiving Day parade.
Didn't know that was a thing.
Super Fun. Totally crazy. Um,
so there's things like that
that I'm exploring. Um,
and then I don't know, we'll see. I'm
excited. Stay tuned. All right, cool.
Cool.
Well
before we open it up to questions, I guess
I would say like, you know, what advice
do you have for fellow seekers like
me?
I definitely don't have answers and I
really do think it is about ultimately
getting still and knowing
that you hound them, you.
Hmm.
Like the,
whoever's telling you that they know,
they know for them but they don't know.
So I know for you that's my, that's my
gut. That's good advice. Yeah. All right.
Thank you. Thank you. Will
you take some questions?
Anybody have any questions?
Not all at once.
Okay.
Hi. Hi. Hi, I'm Susanna.
Thank you so much.
I think it's really interesting
what you spoke about. Um, uh,
definitely would read the book,
but what I'm finding it difficult to is
tying all this together and if you had
to say something like what, what should
the reader take away from this book?
Like is there a, is there an
underlying tank? Like, Hey,
I did this, this, this, this,
and this is what I would conclude
or this is what I would say.
I'm just trying to figure. Yeah. Um,
thank you for your question. I think the,
the conclusion is really
a bit of a non conclusion.
It was sort of like this is an ongoing
journey. This is something that,
it was a very naive of me to think that
I could answer within the pages of a 250
page book. Because if that was possible,
somebody would've done it already. And,
and it was really,
you know,
that I'll be searching probably for the
rest of my life and then I'm okay with
that.
And then the story that I told earlier
about John of God and about the letters
that I've received about for me was really
a conclusion to it was just that you
were all seeking the same things.
And so the health,
happiness and love part of that,
um,
gave me a lot of comfort that ultimately
everyone that I know really wants the
same things.
And if I can focus on that and on the
things that bind us together as opposed to
the things that drive us apart,
especially in times like this, um,
I might be on the past to
something. Thank you. Thank you.
Yeah. Angela, thanks for coming. Hi
Erica. Thanks for being here. Um,
so the tech industry is facing some
really massive questions around
responsibility, accountability, um,
an analog parts of society and the way
we've, yeah, in so many ways. Right.
Sundar was that car in Congress
yesterday. Um, you also mentioned,
it was interesting thinking about how
when you started this journey you were a
little like quiet about it at Google.
And so the third part of this is Jack
Dorsey posted this tweet storm or a few
days ago he did a 10 day silent meditation
treat in Mirror a retreat and Miramar.
Um,
what do you think the space is or
the role is for spirituality in tech?
Um, why is it not talked about
and at the executive level,
do you think it's an important
character trait for a leader? Oh,
that's such a great question,
which I know is not the response
we're supposed to give to a question,
but it really is a great question.
Um, why is it on talked about?
Did you guys watch Silicon Valley?
I mean, I suppose your lists,
I don't want to watch it.
So I had missed seasons of it and there's,
there's like season five or something on
United flights and I was watching like
one episode,
which you can catch on pretty quickly,
but like you can figure
out what's going on.
And it was an episode about one of the
developers who was going to come onto the
plot, the new Internet, um, where they
find out that he's Christian, right?
So it's like he's going to start a gay
dating website and was like, that's cool.
Like that's great. I like the word he's
knew that. And then it's like, wait,
he's Christian. They're like, don't tell
anybody. And it becomes this big thing.
And I thought was so fascinating. So
look, that's what it's like, right?
It's like the last taboo. We talk about
everything now. Nothing's off the table.
But for some reason, the
thing that arguably is one
of the most important things,
like what do you believe about the things
that really matter that really drive
your every day?
And we can't have those conversations.
And I don't know why that is.
I was,
I'm embarrassed to talk about it cause
I really thought everyone would think I
was nuts.
And I'm sure people that,
I remember a conversation at one
of the women at Google events now,
he'd just come back from Brazil and I
was talking to a very senior salesperson
at Google and I was telling her
and you could see her backing away.
She was going hard. Like why?
He's like this woman's crazy. Um,
and it was just such an
interesting experience because
I'm not this like deeply
religious person,
but the fact that I even have to say that
by way of like contextualized and like
don't worry, I'm not religious.
Like I'm just, I'm a secret.
I'm doing a lot of this for fun and I
have to like make people comfortable with
it I think is really interesting.
But the thing that they've also found
interesting is that since I've written
this book,
people come up to me and they spill
forth their religious views or their
spiritual views or their religious
upbringings like a confessional to me now.
So I know all kinds of stuff about people,
people that you know in tech,
not in like all over the planet.
And it's been,
that's been really interesting to me.
So to me there,
there seems to be a clear desire to
talk about these things because people
really do want to get to
the stuff that matters.
And I think until we all started
talking about this stuff,
nothing's gonna Change.
Right?
So is it important for our senior
leadership in a place like Google to talk
about that stuff? I don't know. I
don't want to impose on, you know,
sooner that he should be telling everybody
if he's Hindu and if he's practicing
and if he goes to tumble and
if he believes in God like it,
maybe it doesn't matter.
But I think if that is something that
drives him and it's a belief system that
informs how he leads this company,
I think that's interesting.
I would want to know that.
Just out of curiosity, I
think it'd be interesting. Um,
thank you, Angela. You
for coming. Um, so I,
and myself from of a passenger meditator
and I did the 10 day course and
everything.
Um,
but I am new to New York and I've found
it to be extremely difficult in New York
to like find like 20 minutes
just to like calm down. Um,
so do you have any advice or
tips on how to meditate daily?
You need to get access to the mother's
room at Google and then go in there.
I'm sort of kidding, but it's sort of
true. I think actually focus rooms now.
Focus rooms.
Yes.
We have focus rooms where you're not
supposed to do anything except for sit and
think, wow, I really want to
come back. That is the thing.
I'm joking aside. I
think it's really, it's,
it's being really intentional
about carving out the time
and doing it no matter
what. And I think if you start, when I
did that first TM class, I remember they,
they said that you had to do it for two
months I think or where they're like try
to not break the habit or
the street for two months.
And then it just became a thing I did
where I now I am not a morning person and
I will wake up early to do it.
So if you can,
I would start by just
waking up like if it's 20
minutes, 10 minutes,
whatever your practices,
and then if you're trying to
find space during the day,
if you can block off a meeting,
I would do that.
Okay.
And I think in a place like
Google, people respected, actually,
it's not necessarily
true of other workplaces.
I can tell you that cause they'll be
like, you know, we've got a meeting,
this is the only other time everyone can
meet it and they just schedule over it.
But I feel like here you could
actually carve that space.
Have you done search inside yourself?
No.
So there is a course here
called search inside yourself,
which is essentially a meditation
course. Um, started by, um,
an ex Googler who's an
incredible guy and Mang. Anyway,
so search inside yourself as a
course here and at the end of it, uh,
you get paired up with a fellow.
Why Alumni?
And, um, you know,
the goal is essentially you have meetings
together so that you can carve out the
time to meditate. And if you
write to that, that list,
which is [inaudible] why dash alumni,
I don't know actually a full let me,
he'll be able to access it. But, um,
there are tons of people who I'm sure
would love to set up time with you.
Great.
Thank you.
Hi.
Um,
so I feel like maybe the questions that
you started with in this book and the
questions that kind of started this
talk are generally like universal among
people. And I think that everyone kind
of wonders about a lot of these things.
I'm thinking about like myself personally,
I think my instincts are like my first,
whatever my first movement here would be
to think about exploring the more major
religions in the more
mainstream religions.
And I think that a lot of the stuff
you explored to kind of be a secondary
thought. Okay. Um,
can you talk a little bit more about
your decision to kind of go that route
instead of the more
mainstream religion room?
Yeah,
it's,
it was really because I'm not a theologian
and I didn't feel drawn Tonya them.
So I didn't feel like I could do a real,
uh,
an adequate job of like
exploring Christianity and
then a little bit of Judaism
and then Islam.
It's like,
how do you do that in a meaningful way
with a full time job with the new kid.
And I didn't feel Jon Tenney them
because I don't think this project was
necessarily a rejection of the
religion I was raised with.
If you ask me now like what religion
are you, I'd probably still answer John.
I'm like John Ish. Like people are
Jewish. I'm Jen Esch. You know,
like I think that's still directionally
what I feel makes sense for me because
it's so cultural to me.
So I think because I tied
religion and culture so,
so much together, it would be
like searching for a new culture.
And that wasn't really the project.
But a lot of people have asked
me that question. It just, yeah,
it wasn't something that felt like
the right direction. And so, um,
yeah,
so I went in this kind of other direction,
but everything that I
searched for and everything,
all the experiences that I did were very
much authentically what I felt curious
about. And so it wasn't like,
oh, what, don't make a funny
chapter. I was like, no,
I kind of want to go to burning man
and like I think I want to do a silent
meditation. We give us things
that I actually wanted to try.
Can I ask a followup
question please? Yeah. Um,
can you talk a little bit more
about the title of the book?
Because I feel like this is maybe when it,
like I,
I got is something that I associate
maybe more with mainstream religions then
with other spiritual practices.
Yeah.
And I'd be interested to hear about kind
of your thoughts about the connection
between those and,
right.
Um,
so the original title of the book that
I sold the proposal on was actually from
Google to God and then, and I loved it
and I thought it was really a funny title.
And then my editor halfway through
my writing process was like,
you got to change the title because it
sounds like you left Google to become a
priest. And I was like, oh,
that's true. And that's not
what happens in the spot. Um,
but the idea of it just being a search,
I wanted some reference to the tech kind
of piece of it and the fact that tech
played such a large part,
certainly in my personal journey
and just of life and my career,
but then also in how I was accessing a
lot of these things because so much of it
started with an internet search.
What did you know that was part of the,
the narrative, the stocking
reference. You know,
it's a bit of a provocative
sort of word to use,
but certainly like a Facebook stalking
kind of reference it like, but again,
tongue and cheek. So there was a lot of
thought put into the title and I think,
um,
it can be confusing to people.
There's definitely Amazon reviewers who
do not like my book because they're like,
that's not the answer.
And Christianity is answer whatever.
There's a couple of very angry
people on Amazon and I was like,
well then it's not for you and I get it.
But it was,
it was meant to be a
bit tongue in cheek to,
thank you.
Thanks.
Um, my first question was the same
as his actually my next question was,
is was anybody actually healed like that
you took to the Brazilian healer guy?
Oh, the followup. Like
did anybody ever photos?
So I don't think anyone I brought photos
of was struggling with a real medical
condition of the, of the
batch that I had. Um,
but that's said in followups.
So he also,
John of got also makes a trip to like
Omega Institute in upstate New York.
And so I had gone last year
before my book came up,
came out, I drove up there cause
he was coming and I was Kinda like,
Oh I feel like I should show a picture
of my book cover to them and have them
scan that and heal it.
It's thought we be kind of like
a nice tying up for myself.
I don't know if he did it,
but I watched a picture of the book
cover and is in his bed in his basket.
And I did bring a photograph of a friend
who was just diagnosed with breast
cancer and she is cancer free.
I don't think that did it. I mean she also
had medical treatment, right? Like, but,
but uh, I dunno if it gives
somebody a little bit of hope,
I think that's okay. Yeah.
Cool. Thank you. Yeah.
Hi Angela. Thank you so much
for coming. I really enjoy that.
Especially because last night I had
like my monthly existential crisis,
like taking on like these sorts of ideas.
Um,
and one of the thoughts that came was a,
and this is actually a followup from a
podcast I was listening to earlier this
week, um, was a bit like this,
this sort of rationalist mindset.
The very scientific driven
mindset is fairly modern.
Like it's a byproduct of like the post
industrial revolution movements. And,
um,
it's sort of like when you have that
mindset where like we want to critically
analyze, okay, why is this happening? I
found that like even doing meditation,
like my first thought
after it, it's like, okay,
it felt something but like why did I
feel that it has to be something like
neurological process that's causing this?
Like clearly it has to be a
rational explanation for that.
So when you're doing all of these
like very unorthodox things,
like did you find that you
needed to suspend that sort
of mindset of like, okay,
how like there has to be clearly
rational way to explain like why this has
happened?
Yeah, 100%. So if, um,
when you read my book is a way that the,
the narrative really plays off that way.
I,
there's,
there's like this a very lawyerly part
of me that does the research and we'll
talk about oxytocin release during a
hug and like what that might mean if,
and that's why hugging him,
I could be effective because of that.
But then the other side is kind of like,
well,
what's the feeling like she smelled
really nice. Like it was a little sweaty,
a little uncomfortable, but like it was
awesome and that, that juxtaposition,
I mean it was constant. Like it
was a constant dialogue in my head.
It continues to be just the way I
work and navigate the world. Um,
but that was very, very hard for me and
I would keep flipping back and forth.
And I do address it a lot in the book
cause I think that's so much of, uh,
so many of us are in the same position
where it's like we're raised to think of
very specific way or educated
and overeducated sort of
repeating things again
and again to be come experts at something.
And then here's this whole
set of questions that are
truly not Google a wall.
You will not find a satisfactory answer.
You will find people who are reporting
to know the answers on Google to all of
these questions.
Um,
I would challenge that maybe
their incorrect answers on Google.
You need to tweak the algorithm
on these particular things,
but there are just things that are
unknowable. And so if you start,
you know, I don't know how
you reconcile those things,
but I kind of flipped back and forth to,
but then ultimately it was like
I just got to suspend disbelief,
like I can't try to explain these things
otherwise I'll just be stuck in a loop.
Just as a small follow up the week
when you were actually having these
experiences, did you like just like push
aside any of the thoughts that are like,
okay, why is this happening? Why is that?
No,
I think I did it really unsuccessfully.
There were moments that I would like the,
the tantric sound healing being a perfect
example. There are moments I was like,
this is so weird. Like my head was
like, oh my God, I cannot believe,
do I and I should not be doing this.
My parents like, what would they think?
Like they're going to hear about this. I'm
going to write, I can't write about it.
Like I was going on and I was like,
this is bananas. I am married.
Like what am I doing? You know? It
was just like a loop, a loop, a loop.
And then there are moments where it's
kind of like, all right, just like relax,
just breathe into it. And I was
like, oh, it's got a nice oily,
like this is him. This is bizarre. But it
also kind of not altogether unpleasant.
And then so, and then
I'd be like, oh my God,
I can't believe this man laying on
top of me. This is very awkward. Um,
and so it would just be
like a constant thing.
And not for me is also my meditation
cycle is like the monkey mind of the loop
of like, what's going on? I have to
make dinner, I have to go to this thing.
I forgot to pick up the dry cleaning,
blah, blah, blah. And I'm like, Oh,
I'm just be meditating and like munch
a bunch of much, much. I'm like, ah.
And I'm like, crap, did I fall asleep?
And I'd just keep going. And you know,
it's like constant and I think, um, I
feel like that's the very human journey.
I don't live in the woods, right? Like,
I don't live on a meditation farm.
I live in New York City. I lived downtown.
I take the subway, I walk everywhere.
Like it is hectic and I think
that's just part of our life.
But if you can push that reset
button every day in some way,
and the fact that you're just asking them
questions I think is great, you know.
Thank you. Going back this
way. Huh? Nice to see you.
Thank you for coming in.
Um, how did you know,
it sounds like you got to a point where
you felt at peace that like the search
you had searched enough,
you didn't find specific answers
and you were okay with that.
Can you describe that?
Because when you're just talking about
the constant loop and it's really hard to
break that cycle,
how did you feel fulfilled on this journey
and what was that moment like? Yeah,
there are a couple of
things that drove that.
I think one was definitely the silent
meditation experience of just being still
for that long. I didn't do a full 10
days. I tell that story of why I'm fuck,
but it's, I did a five day retreat
and uh, by the end and I was like,
I think,
I think I'm good for a minute.
Like I feel like just stopping and I
just need to sit with what I've already
researched and sort of be in that, um,
and, and feel like I have enough data,
you know, to lead Gen form
something that felt right.
And then also, truthfully, it was
partially because I was on deadline.
It was like I can't keep
searching and I can't,
I've got to turn this book in and I have
to be okay with not having a conclusion
because I'm not going to in
time for this book to come out.
And so either I can spend the rest of
my life writing this book and it will be
written and published post humorously
or I can try to wrap this up and be okay
with the knowledge that I will never
know the answer to these questions.
And that's where he chose to land.
Sorry, one more, one more question.
Um,
it sounds like the impetus of this search
was more about your daughter and the
question she might have as she grows
older. When did you decide, hey,
this is a book and I should probably
put this out there for more people to
absorb? Ooh, that's a
good question. You know,
there was a moment where it was going to
be a film and then I realized I did not
want to be in a film.
And so that was pushed aside and then I,
but I felt like there was something I
wanted to do with it because it was fun in
anyone. I would tell the stories too
would be like, you have to ride the salad.
These are such funny stories or
they're really interesting or whatever,
depending on what story was.
Um,
so I started taking better notes
as I would do things. And then, uh,
I met an agent a few years ago and he
was like, you've got to write this.
Like this is a book. I know I can sell
it. And that's what ended up happening.
So it's sort of,
I never set out to write a book.
It just sort of it and it sounds
like such a jerky thing to be like,
it's just sort of happened, but that's
kind of what happened. It felt like,
you know Jesus took the wheel. No, I'm
just joking. I that's not inappropriate,
but I just, I feel like
it does. They just,
it's sort of just played out the
way it was meant to I think. Yeah.
Even question,
how forthcoming were you when you
went and traveled around and met with
different,
like when you went to the and potluck,
did they ask you why you were there?
Did you tell them and if so,
what was the response? I was
incredibly forthcoming. I am a lawyer.
I do not want to get sued by anybody. I
wasn't trying to dupe anybody. I was very,
very clear that I was,
once I decided to turn it into a book,
I was very clear that I was writing
a book and for anybody that was prior
chapters,
I reached out to people to make sure that
they were okay with what I was writing
because everything in the book was true.
And so anyone that,
I certainly if I named them,
I gave everyone the opportunity to change
our name or to read what I was writing.
So I didn't want anyone to feel made
fun of or you know, like thought,
like kind of side swiped from what I was
writing because it was not meant to be
like a takedown of, of all these
different practices. So I was very,
very forthcoming when I,
when I did it. Thank you.
From the legal team of
Google for asking. Yeah. Um,
were there any ways in which you feel
like your life has been changed in either
positive or negative ways that you were
not expecting after the experience?
From the research or just
the whole experience reading
anything? Yeah. Oh yeah.
It's opened up in ways that I wouldn't
have expected for sure. I think just,
you know,
what it did was one of the habits I think
I learned working at Google actually
was to be ready for anything and to
really put myself into uncomfortable
situations. Right. Like,
again, as a lawyer,
you're trying to like know something to
go really deep on that issue to really
be the expert.
And working at Google in the years
that I did that was not going to be the
situation. It was like,
here's a new product,
we're launching this other thing and
you just have to go figure it out.
And working that muscle here,
um,
I think led to me being really comfortable
going into these very uncomfortable
situations for the research for this
book and has become a theme of both my
career and my personal life
since then where it's been like,
it's just opened up all these things
because something like becoming a clown in
the Macy's Thanksgiving Day parade,
like that is not something I would ever
have thought I would do. And I went,
I had so much fun and it was so goofy
and it was such a delightful thing to do.
And I think it's because I worked at
Google and then did something like this
that I'm willing to put myself out there
and sort of suck the marrow out of life
while I'm here. And I think
that's definitely what this
has taught me. For sure.
Yeah. Thank you, Angela. Faye coming.
And I think if we've learned anything,
it's that in addition to wanting love and
health and what was the APP enough and
happiness, I think also everybody
kind of wants to know. Yeah. What's
it all about? So thanks for bringing
us together to talk about that. And,
and um,
if you haven't read the book yet,
I highly recommend it. So much fun. Such
a fun journey at the back of the room.
Pick up a copy and it's nice to see
you all. Thank you all for being here.
Thank you so much.